[Musik]
hallo hallo tina wie geht's hallo lisa
mir geht es super danke und dir sehr gut
danke was machst du ich bin gerade in
der stadt auf shoppingtour
ich brauche unbedingt ein neues kleid du
wirst nicht glauben warum
ach ja erzählen warum brauchst du ein
neues kleid
ich habe gestern tanja getroffen sie hat
mir erzählt dass die bald heiraten wird
sie hat mir gesagt dass ich natürlich
auch eingeladen bin wow ich freue mich
so für sie
das ist schön aber es tut mir leid wer
ist tanja
sie ist eine gute freundin von mir du
hast sie letztes jahr kennengelernt
tanja wo habe ich sie kennengelernt
auf der party von thomas sie hat das
essen gekocht
wie sieht sie aus sie hat blonde haare
und ist ziemlich groß ich erinnere mich
nicht wie alt ist sie sie ist 33 jahre
alt genau wie ich und woher kommt sie
sie kommt aus münchen naja jetzt
erinnere ich mich
sie war damals sehr unglücklich weil sie
keinen freund hatte richtig ja genau und
jetzt heiratet sie
wow das ist ja schnell gegangen seit
wann kennt sie denn ihren freund erst
seit vier monaten und wann heiratet sie
und im juni das gilt ja schnell
wo wird sie heiraten in rapperswil in
diesem schönen schloss das klingt ja
fantastisch wie viele gäste hat sie
eingeladen
sie haben etwa 100 leute eingeladen
glaube ich wow da planen sie aber ein
großes fest ja ich freue mich schon aber
ich habe noch nichts anzuziehen
na du wirst schon etwas finden
ich wünsche dir viel glück vielen dank
wir sehen uns dann am samstag richtig ja
richtig weißt du peter wird
[Musik]